à première vue ça ressemble à un écran
de Minitel classique mais en y regardant
de plus près ça n'a en fait rien à voir
cet écran extra plat encore à l'état de
prototype n'utilise pas de tube
cathodique comme sur les écrans
traditionnels minitel ou récepteur télé
le texte ou l'image s'inscrit sur un
écran plat à cristaux liquide grâce à
quelques 80000 mini transistors répartis
à l'intérieur d'un écran de 10 cm/ 13
moins encombrant qu'un Minitel à tube
cathodique il permet d'effectuer les
mêmes types d'opérations de plus en
utilisant un transistor pour chaque
point d'image on obtient un contraste et
un angle de vue
excellent cet écran est directement
compatible avec que l'ancien système
Minitel il suffit presque de remplacer
le tube cathodique classique par notre
écran à cristau liquide le gros avantage
qu'on y voit dans cet écran cristau
liquide c'est que la consommation
électrique est bien moindre et on peut
imaginer à partir d'un tel écran des
systèmes complètement autonome et donc
portable pour sortir ce prototype il
aura u plus de 3 ans de recherche à
l'équipe du Centre d'études des
télécommunications de l'anion et
investir entre 10 et 15 millions de
francs dans ce laboratoire conçu tout
spécialement pour réaliser la matrice de
transistor c'est-à-dire à l'abri de
toute
poussière actuellement l'écran
fonctionne en noir et blanc mais d'ici
quelques semaines il affichera la
couleur en outre on pense d'ors et déjà
à étendre son application à la
télévision un domaine où il faudra aussi
compter sur la concurrence japonaise oui
c'est vrai il y a un grand nombre de
laboratoires japonais avec des forces
extrêmement importantes qui travaille
sur le même projet ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui c'est que les produits
finaux montrés par les Japonais sont
effectivement très beaux mais
l'originalité de notre procédé réside
dans sa simplicité cette simplicité
introduisant un nombre de défauts
beaucoup plus restreints et des
rendements normalement beaucoup plus
grands pour protéger cette invention de
portée internationale le knnet a bien
sûr déposé des brevets en France et à
l'étranger prochaine étape trouver des
structures industriell capable de
fabriquer ce type d'écran au rythme de
10000 par an notamment au niveau
européen le prix de VI un tel système
n'a pourtant pas encore été calculé quoi
qu'il en soit sachez qu'il sera
désormais possible dans un avenir proche
de sortir de sa poche un écran de la
taille d'un paquet de cigarette et de
jouer par exemple au maxitel
FR3